welcome to this video playing The
Invisible Man international masa
Invisible Man from Russia yep no name
okay I went 44
just to get some variety in okay a six
that's um that's early mmm-hmm let's say
yeah I just trying to play some
classical good moves okay okay very
quickly decided to take on D form
I don't know it was so ridiculous this
idea what I played here to take on
before I mean I understand that he's got
the better Center but I was thinking
that my development should should count
for something a five takes Bishop d2 and
black resigns yeah so is he wants to go
to a 7 B 5 so this is this is really
really bad for black he's completely
unimpressed obviously just playing
innocent moves all the time ok so let's
see take Bishop c6 strong I think but
not not the only continuation let's see
I can go Knight g5 ready for is also not
bad
yeah I don't know many good
continuations hard to determine what's
best in with this typically limited time
Bishop g5 or I mean I want to put
pressure on the e pawn not sure how to
play it yeah not the same little time is
limited
yeah he will probably play e5 it looks
loose with the King but don't see how to
exploit it
maybe Bishop d7 Knight beehive this kind
of thing and I would the head AF bonus
most I can take here take on d7
I don't know very difficult maybe
difficult
check yeah I missed something earlier
pretty pretty clearly because I don't
really think that this was any good
what black played him but couldn't
really refute it convincingly some night
c5 Knight c3 check for Queen G form
okay I can't go 24 now and look at your
money
check now this is defending of course
hmm yeah it's not exactly difficult even
now I was stupid stupid play
that's not much that I can do here
really
yeah just a piece down he can take on
any form but just for simplifying
matters but I know I can also resign
actually but I'm a little bit too
frustrated to do that
check after I didn't manage to refute
this this bad opening plane okay it's of
course completely winning from black
it's funny that he's now investing time
you have had this very easy win but all
the difficult things he played instantly
okay yeah let's take it yeah I mean it's
losing in any any case rookie rupee for
simply simply on I can give the trick
here time morning no I'm just this end
game it's just lost probably okay with
the b-pawn yeah it's still lost even if
I can promote the a porn it will be a
very problematic with reports against
against the for the exchange
yeah
you know a seven there was to check on
you three so for a Bishop c5 check back
here yeah a agents not really not really
helping but what can you do check its to
jump too many pawns as simple as that
check check
maybe it's even managing to do this it
would be quite deserving but Jeff I
don't don't see how to win Jess actually
check
I want evil queen no I didn't see I
didn't see it check check what a what a
what a weird game yeah what a weird game
Jeff it's ah yeah I mean can I win this
here against the pants it's not so easy
king of two now of course I'm winning
him but I didn't I didn't manage I
didn't manage Luke h6s is just a soupçon
of course I okay it here then I can take
okay this this game should have been
over like mu 15 or so and because this
is just completely bonkers yeah this
Queen b6 and stuff can I cannot believe
that like is going to to survive this
kind of thing but how do I actually how
do I refute it I mean it's this this one
and now a queen takes a strong move I
didn't think about that
I mean okay hmm
so look he won Knight f6 and queen takes
is actually stronger mmm now this this
wasn't really occurring to me why is
this so strong
which exit the beam night eggs okay one
thing I'm recognizing now he still
cannot castle simply because of this
move
what alternatively here it's just
overloaded and this means he has a huge
problem with knight c6 coming and not
easy it should be three I mean why does
clearly better here but I couldn't take
it simply couldn't refute it totally f3m
not a happy meal if I huh well he's okay
there are the computer confirms I have
spot the lot lots of my chances earlier
here Bishop g5 s is very strong this
should be three looks tempting man but
this is stronger one key point is that
he still cannot Castle yeah I can just
take and it's it's overloaded him this
is his piece this should be three was a
stupid move really
mmm yeah this is a very problematic
position from black yes he has a hard
time to move even something I'm
threatening Bishop f6 winning this piece
and let's say Bishop here I'm going like
a six for example and now make a move
and I cannot castle because of rupees
seven and there are some technical
things already in for example stuff like
that it's pretty strong the a pawn hangs
and so on
it's simply that you violated tons of
opening principles and I mean just
taking then one second this is this kind
of cheeky ax me you can also do this
which is really not clear instead he is
grabbing a part while being
underdeveloped in the middle and giving
me tons of Tempe boots but quite cheeky
but it worked
yeah yeah here this is not not yet not
clear or great or whatever here I mean I
have some fishy attacking chances but
it's not really really working we had
game but I didn't really punish him in
the in the early stages I was trying to
be relatively quick about it maybe I
should have thought a little bit more
about some moves like Bishop e3 here
Bishop g5 is really much stronger it is
much stronger now okay thanks for
watching